hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five nights at Freddy's 4
Oh movies behind me by me
laughs are you yeah you're supposed to
keep me safe Freddy okay so the first
night is never usually that bad in any
of the game so I'll play through [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] oh the night actually
seems to be going quicker than the past
nights probably because there's not as
much
who's that really oh I think I'd event
raising jakku you go I gotta clear the
pest from my desk or my bed
my damn bed my death bed ah probably the
worst cuz I've died twice on the first
night my crown is slipping from my head
Oh No
why God's vive dates to the Devvarman
the first time I tried this it was easy
I got the 5 a.m. I didn't even try I
didn't even read the instructions I mean
that might be mom making me a tasty
sandwich yeah back off take your cupcake
I'm Ram it up your butt my flashlights
probably dying
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] don't do that Oh soo
cute he's too cute I wish you'd go to
hell anjaii he's so cute
come on get to 6 a.m. damn it I should
be able to witness hi what the bag why
that was golden freddy holy crap this is
gonna be impossible No
oh oh I think I saw something throw me
out to tag it where you going and three
of them